foreign
[Music]
you shouldn't make things up when we're
talking about
can you open the door please
I'm not here to hurt you but you have to
stay here in the cabin with us families
throughout history have been chosen to
make this decision your family must
choose to willingly sacrifice one of the
three of you to prevent the apocalypse
we're not sacrificing anyone for every
no you give us
hundreds of thousands of people are
going to die
sweetheart close your eyes
will you make a choice
you have to suck more normal people just
like you it doesn't matter none of us
believe you we will never choose anyone
[Music]
I'm afraid the rule is that no one's
allowed to leave until you choose
do you really think it's all just a
coincidence I have to believe that my
son is gonna die his name is Charlie as
a mother I am begging you apparently
Andrew I saw something there was
something in the light
yeah I feel it now
you fail to choose a world will perish
we've been given the chance to decide
the fate of everyone Conjuring out of
the world
there's nothing more flawed and perfect
in this world than our family believe
like a choice
always together always together
then we'll ask for the last time will
you make a choice
[Music]
sorry to interrupt are you okay I need
to get out of a toxic relationship
once you start by telling us what
brought you here
my boss is different you can't get him
out of your head no I need your
assistance
oh you feel like he could destroy you
with the snap of his fingers wouldn't
even need to snap
okay oh that sounds familiar yeah what
[Music]
innocent victims
I want a hundred of nuns a bus load of
cheerleaders
and I just went to normal life again
that this modern world is a dangerous
place
no no no no no no
foreign
thank you you saved my life did I watch
you cut a guy's arms off with a
decorative serving platter it's all in
the wrist
my boss gave me this power
turn I tend to his needs including care
feeding you bring and people to eat
you're like the guy that gets the
villains Postmates but if you were to
stop focusing on his needs what would
happen
he won't grow to full power exactly he
won't grow to full power what that's so
weird why would you phrase it like that
but yes
well come on
to most
I am
okay obviously we're dealing with a
little bit more than just narcissism
here
now that's it
Captain Torrance how can I help you
fugitive extradition oh is he dangerous
what did he do homicide 15 years ago I
don't want to scare the rest of the
passengers I'm afraid you're stuck with
this Captain
[Music]
Mr captain speaking the seatbelt signs
have been turned on
nothing else
this Island's run by separatists and
militias
invite passengers my responsibility
I'm gonna need your help I'm gonna need
this
why'd they lock you up no one cares what
really happens
no need to worry folks these planes are
pretty much indestructible
January 13th
you're an interesting man
Scotland
you're an Avenger
[Music]
you have a daughter
but you've lost a lot of time like me
we could help each other with that
how are you
I'm the man who can give you the one
thing you want
what's that
time
you're right existence
and shatter timelines
you cannot trust him I don't care who
this guy is I just lost so much
[Music]
he can give us a second chance
[Music]
let me make this easy for you
he will bring me what I need
or everything you call a life will end
up
you may not want her to watch this we
had a deal
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
sir the police are here please
detective can we talk about this
I'm gonna pay you for your time
stop he's not a cop this is what my son
does he plays these games all that work
for one thousand dollars
if you're gonna steal
a lot
what are you doing here just wanted to
say hi I had a good time all right cool
see you around dad
I always assumed my son would inherit
all this he doesn't have the fortitude
he's weak
you like him a little bit
of course they like him he's a
billionaire
we're celebrating what exactly are we
celebrating billions of dollars
roll up your sleeves trust me
you can't cheat on us man
that's why we never feel sorry for the
mark I really like you I really like
kids now you lied to me we're all we're
all human just doing the best we can you
cause your mother anguish and I will not
have it she wants me gone
how do you think it says
not well
[Music]
what did you tell him I'm gonna take a
billion dollars and aim it in your
direction
[Music]
through
this is real
sure
[Music]
the strands in your eyes they color them
one I've been looking forward to this
moment ever since baby Tommy was cut out
of my abdomen cheers everybody
[Music]
it's time
where is the pattern of the pride
Robert Robert they're calling you thanks
a lot Carol
here's the plan we're gonna head to the
next Island for help on my count ten
nine why are you counting from ten but
is this a rocket launch you can find on
four this weekend hasn't exactly got a
plan Pirates chasing he wasn't on your
vision board you're the only thing on my
mission is that blood
[Music]
okay yeah just you know I looked over
there and I saw the blood and you know I
think I saw some brain was that brain
stuff well you know what maybe we should
let's just step away
[Music]
I am so sorry
for what your daddy passed down to you
I wanted a child
gift of my life
I'm visiting my mother tomorrow
hi Karen it's Mom I'm just calling to
say that I'm so so so excited to see you
tomorrow you're my angel and I love you
okay I love you okay bye sweetie I love
you
are you at the airport I'm on my way I
just
it's not safe is it
what do you think I should do
I'm sure you'll do the right thing
sweetheart
welcome back I hit you with my car
what
oh
what was this that's my little assistant
health monitor
feeling sad about going home
us feel totally unreal
I'm supposed to be leaving I don't know
if that's gonna happen
[Music]
you will walk many miles
dozens will become hundreds
[Music]
hundreds will become thousands
your adventures will continue for years
and years this is a good hold I know
[Music]
it's not for me
do you want the truth now
[Music]
[Music]
Ally
Sean oh my God what are you doing here
you know I'm just visiting my old haunts
on the off chance I might run into an X
from 10 years ago how many of you
running two so far
foreign
[Music]
if you hadn't left all those years ago
I've been kind of wondering the same
thing recently like if maybe I made the
wrong decision
I haven't felt that free in
I don't even know how long Sean honey
Mom hey I
what a wonderful thing for us all to be
here so thank you to the bride and groom
for giving us a reason to celebrate to
Sean and Cassidy
I need to see this through whatever it
is you mean like with you in the groom
we can just call him Sean
hi if you're still here if my being here
is making you uncomfortable no no it
wouldn't be very cool of me to kick out
one of Sean's oldest friends
[Music]
[Applause]
I thought she was cool she actually
reminds me a lot of me at that age
were he like a nudist I was I have an
idea
keep your eyes on the iPad Bradley's hit
Campbell do not taste the naked ladies
this has gone way too far I don't know I
don't know what to do anymore
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
we
do it is
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
shelter
let's see
okay
[Music]
voila
[Music]
we imagine a future
and our imaginings horrifiers
they won't fear it
until they understand it
[Music]
and they won't understand it
until they've used it
Theory will take you only so far
foreign
[Music]
ever
going to tell the truth
no matter what's Happening Here
foreign since the beginning of time
since the first little girl ever existed
there have been dolls
but the dolls were always and forever
baby dolls
until
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
it was a perfect day
and all I could think about was how much
I wanted to cut you all open and then
climb inside your bodies
[Music]
so that we could stay one happy family
[Laughter]
when I was just a little girl
I asked my mother
what is this Danny I found it what will
I be
[Music]
ready
[Music]
here's what she said to me
oh not now
you don't look so good mom nothing a big
old kiss from you won't fix
any bath oh yeah
yeah you know how to lie to kids
set up
[Applause]
[Music]
mom Mommy's with the maggots now
what will be will be
this isn't a vacation it's a quarantine
we're the only people around here
foreign
it's a quarantine a quarantine inspired
are you kidding me
this is incredible sick and it's all
ours the only neighbor is Miles Away
I thought you were spending quarantine
alone what are you doing here I wanted
to see you and quarantine can be fun
[Music]
thank you
Mary
jump in water's fine who is this I don't
know that's creepy Parker
[Music]
oh my God just one moment I'm off the
door
you have a mess don't you you're mad
what I can't let you in it's not safe
are you kidding me lately
no texting and driving only when I'm
texting you
hey okay now
[Music]
hey buddy
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
who were those
women where is everyone but we're gonna
have to figure this out
oh yeah you shouldn't be in there
we are not helping him hey we need to
stick together all the landlines are
dead there's no cell phone signal and
none of us have found a door to get out
of here
this will not end well unless work
together
Sam
who the hell are they
hello 9-1-1
I am getting out of here no matter what
it takes
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
I'm here to speak to you today about
your changing body the blood is released
through the vagina
cease to this one thing for me
let me just be normal and regular like
everybody else just please please please
please please please please please
please
[Music]
I've decided I want you to join my
secret Club
if you want to be in the club then you
have to wear a bra
oh
do you you think you need one
are you okay you can tell me the truth
fine good yes we have the campus
Improvement connection any volunteers
social committee fundraising committee
and how are you I read that when you
don't have any loved ones around your
life expectancy drops drastically but
you know I've had a good run
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
Let It Be A Lady
do you think any of us will look like
that when we're 19.
we must we must we must increase
[Music]
guys we are here with the stars of super
Society Adam Clark and his girlfriend
you are heading down to Mexico to wrap
up the trilogy we're hosting Hollywood
royalty for the next few weeks so you
want me to babysit the
50
Locos
doing his silent meditation
hey
um I'm in character so this doesn't
count right
best thing you can do for you right now
is to say absolutely nothing about the
breakup every
Sophie Wilder you are the one I think
it's the short end of the stick it's you
I'm not talking about
domestic I don't know if it's short or
not I didn't look at the nudes when they
leaked I just made them go away
sad
I heard an audiobook that said you're
supposed to lean into that like let
yourself be sad
who are you I'm Alejandro the junior
manager for the hotel I'm really sorry
about the towels uh have a great stay oh
my God he walked down you're completely
naked good evening Miss Wilder late
night call me Sophie you have seen me
naked I wasn't looking well now I'm
offended night
hi Miss Wilder I was wondering can I
take a tour I'd actually like to go
dancing I'd be happy to assist you with
that what time
at midnight
hey
[Music]
you were totally falling for her she's
leaving soon this can't go anywhere the
idea of us getting back together it's
got legs he cheated on you this guy's a
monster it was a five-year relationship
kind of complicated isn't it
[Music]
I wish we could go somewhere we didn't
have to hide
what are we doing where is she what the
hell is going on this was a huge mistake
because I'm not on vacation I'm supposed
to be here for work
I'm just
[Music]
I mean cheating it's it's actually very
hip it's very French you know why do you
think we all go to can every year for
the movies
now
[Music]
[Music]
detective Knight what do you think makes
a good cop the good cop doesn't sleep
well so everyone else can
awesome
most cops are good
cops are our enemies you said he wanted
a real way to make change this is our
chance
down
do you guys think the world would be a
better place without you in it
I got your answer right here
coming so a uniform badge gun
the city is tearing itself apart
ready
the world needs Heroes
[Music]
if they bring a tank called me
when you look outside do you see the
American dream
let's go
angel of Justice
[Music]
I'm gonna have to meet you in there I've
only just finished my last valuation
[Music]
the office clown award goes to Raylene
Brad Delaney
[Music]
you don't really fit in in any office
you've got fired and quit but in the
same day well that's new what are you
going to do
how long have you been performing Dolly
no no it was just an unfortunate mistake
we're casting for a new Dolly at the
moment let's see what you're made of
she's brat she's bubbly
nipples to the sky greenbrush
oh wow makeup's a little extra
thank you very much you strike me as
someone who doesn't stick to things this
is where I belong this is what I'm
supposed to be doing baby I'm burning
out of control yeah you're weird enough
I'll give you that so I'm gonna throw
you a Boat Show Me What You're Made Of
[Music]
there are two kinds of people those who
know how to have a good time and those
who are willing to learn
you're off on some wild sequined goose
chase that isn't gonna end well I'm
fighting too constantly what I said
starting oh God mum I'm not an idiot and
it will and well if it kills me Dolly
are dead
what happened it's fine it's not fun you
look crazy but just get it together okay
[Music]
thank you
thank you very much
thank you very much has he left the
building yet
[Music]
everything all right in there trying to
have a private moment my bad
not that private then
how you doing yeah good yeah yeah
go go
it's Tom right let me ask that's me
I'm gonna meet my ex for the first time
since the breakup and you're still
calling it The Breakup we're fine we
were better than fun we moved in
together but we had Hamilton tickets
it's a serious commitment
so what happened she cheated on me with
my best friend
with him oh that hurts a little bit I
mean I got it the arms are nice but why
don't you even talk about are you just
gonna sit there and say that to me well
she said my answer
I went through the same sort of thing
not too long ago she was his life coach
apparently she opened his mind and then
her legs all of her underwear looks like
this seriously you'd have to sew like 15
of these together to get the pants I'm
wearing right now the worst part I left
my favorite record at his place let's go
find a record shop right now and I'll
buy you a new coffee but I don't want
any coffee I want my copy yeah he must
have changed the locks back I'm gonna
break in someone must have a keeper
juices go I'll keep them chatting you
look for the key room for one more
what the hell do you think you're doing
no I wasn't
um
I just caught this boy going through
your knicker drawer what have you done
[Music]
sometimes you just gotta see what
happens just go where the breeze takes
you
are you sure you're done for this
yeah
by the way your man swapped me on Tinder
like a week ago
give me your phone or anybody now
oh
I got a big hike plan for us tomorrow
can we just do some fun indoor
activities yeah like uh drinking
is this still even a trail wow
before I don't even think that goes I
don't know
gives me the creeps let's go
rise and shine sleepyheads where do the
kids go they can't go far I'm still
trying to understand how you let them
out of yourself when we woke up they
were gone
guys
guys there you are no no no stop no
Jesus Christ
hey Ben look at me
whoa hey hey
you good man
how you been feeling lately I know what
I saw
can I show you something in the woods
I don't think that's them out there
anymore I promise we're better than ever
this is your fault
what did you do to your mom Spencer
you want to play a game with you
ready or not here we come
we want to play with you now
[Music]
foreign
Legion Academy if you want it you could
train here think of them as the Futures
Justice League
it is so great to meet you I'm monel
this is the rest of the academy trainees
lines destroying Justice and preventing
War
cousin is a problem she failed to
control her powers Brainiac
I am not going to let you hurt anyone
else with her abilities that makes her a
threat I don't like what you're implying
no idea where the rest of the Legion is
I've seen the dark circle come on we
don't have very much time it's up to us
so let's go be heroes
[Music]
foreign
[Music]